hi everyone that was maps by maroon 5
which is indicative of this talk wheeze
I'm gonna show you some maps so my talk
is called data science vacant spatial
and I work at the Center for a spatial
data science so I thought it would look
stupid if it was like data science make
it spatial and then I was Angela lead
center for spatial data science so it
says University of Chicago which is
where I work so without further ado a
little bit about me I am the our spatial
advocate at the Center for spatial data
science at you Chicago which is a
mouthful
basically i'ma want to be Maura avrech
and I look at a lot of maps so that's
what that job is I also help researchers
do their research whatever I just I just
want to be more a brick okay I'm the
founder of Our Lady Chicago and we
started last year July 2017 this is
actually a photo from the launch in it
I'm speaking so I've done this at least
once before I wrote a thesis using
spatial econometrics whoo about property
values in Detroit under Luke insulin who
literally wrote the book on spatial
econometrics
it's called spatial econometrics
I was going to talk about spatial
econometrics but I learned from
econometrics be that you should not talk
about econometrics after 3:00 p.m. in
the afternoon so I'm just gonna show you
some nice maps so um I want to talk a
bit about geography geography when most
people hear this term this is what they
think of this is a map from Lord of the
Rings but I'm here to tell you that
geography can and does involve data
science look at this cool app geography
currently is used in all sorts of
decision support tools we work with
public health officials and we do
cutting-edge social science research we
look at air pollution and I think Rogers
talk about air pollution actually
dovetails with some of the work that
we've done at our Center with Chicago
air pollution and I believe right here
this is a app about medical services so
before we get to the really cool
interesting part of making you know
shiny apps and things with with spatial
data before we get to that we have to do
exploratory spatial data analysis what
is that what is as Duff it basically is
making a ton of Maps this is not how I
make maps by the way when I searched
Matt making all there was was this
person putting pins in a map and then
like linking string to it which is not
part of my day-to-day routine but it
looks very meditative so I might start
doing this if I got really frustrated
with my code one day okay so the way I
thought I would demonstrate what ESDA or
exploratory spatial data analysis was
was by looking at data so what I did was
pull the crimes in DC in the last 30
days from the DC open data portal and I
read it into our the wonder of our now
is that you can actually use it as a GIS
so you can do a lot of the GIS work that
you used to do and for example ArcGIS or
QGIS in our and you can work with
spatial data and our in ways that you
could never have previously
SF was released last year and 2017 it's
really sort of revolutionized how I work
with spatial data so what I'm doing here
is essentially reading in a Geo JSON
which is like a JSON but has geo in it
and reading it into our and I'm looking
at observations if you're familiar with
SF it is essentially a data frame or a
table and on the end of it is tact one
column that's special it's a geometry
column and these can be points polygons
and other things of course the first
thing I wanted to do was make a map so
this is all the crimes that happen in DC
in the last 30 days I just threw it into
leaflet you know the first thing I want
to do is I want to see my data I want to
look at it this is the equivalent to
making a scatterplot ggplot you just
want to look at your data just see
what's there and I'm able to zoom in and
out because it's in leaflet ah maybe I
can't zoom in okay oh very exciting so I
think this is where we are right now no
crimes nice all right just we wait after
maybe after this conference they'll be
some I don't know I think well maybe
people just haven't reported in this
area who knows okay so I've made a map
and now I'm like oh I don't like dots
I like surfaces so I'm gonna change it
into a heat map so I'm using the leaflet
extras package and I'm like ooh look
I've made this like cool heat map of
things and I'm like you know there's hot
spots everywhere I feel like I'm I'm you
know in some sort of TV show where we're
all like looking at hot spots and like
pinpointing crimes cool very fun
the problem with heat maps is this and I
don't know if you can see this or if
you've seen this xkcd comic before and
what it essentially says is if you plot
um counts by area it often just reflects
population so in this comic we see that
our sites users
has this map the second one is
subscribers to Martha Stewart Living and
the third one is consumers of free
pornography and this guy's say the
business implications are clear so the
caption of course is geographic profile
maps which are just population maps so
counts are not that great you know they
can give you a sense of you know where
things are clustered you can get an idea
of where things are but if you want to
do actual analysis you want something
that's a little bit more spatially
intensive I want to adjust for
population the thing about population is
population data is collected in very
specific units and those units are
census tract polygons and so the US
Census you know happens every ten years
counts all the people and counts them in
these little oh sorry in these strange
little buckets called census tracts
census tracts are the smallest unit that
you can get population data at you can
get these in larger chunks you can have
blocks and block groups and they're
slightly larger but tracks is generally
the most granular form of data you can
work with so for example if we zoom in
to where we are you can see that the
mall is just one giant census tract
which makes sense because no one really
lives on the mall and you know there's
there are some other tracks to do that
maybe I want to add crimes as a layer
and so you can see in my code that I've
just put another line that says add
circles the crime data with a lot with
you know colored red I can zoom in a bit
more and take a look at you know where
the dots are in relations to tracks I
noticed that there might be some you
know more dots in this little area right
here for some reason to Georgetown there
are a lot of crimes reported so I'm like
cool this is interesting but there's no
way that I can you know sit there and
count each one of these dots by hand and
that's where spatial joint comes in so
the question I'm really asking is how
many crimes happened in each tract
this is a question of spatial
aggregation so if you have points and
you're going to appalling on your
aggregating up by the spatial unit also
called point in polygon analysis that's
essentially what geographers are saying
when they say point in polygon there are
points which are presenting you know
houses or any sort of data you might
want and then there are polygons which
are you know census tracts block groups
counties zip codes so I really want to
count points in the polygons normally
you might do this with a GIS software
you can now use R as a GIS software I'm
going to use this thing called spatial
join this is from the SF package again
and so I'm gonna spatial join
essentially the crime and then the
tracks and I want to pull out the census
tract from the census tracts Geographic
data what this does is instead of
joining on a common column it joins on a
common geography so for all the points
on the left and if they fall within one
of the geometries of the polygons on the
right so DC tracks they will be joined
to that so a point I should have shown
an example of this I'll show you what
the data frame looks like in a bit if a
point falls within a polygon it will
have that Associated census track
attached to it so I get an error
STC RS x equals equals st c RS y is not
true what does this mean you know I just
wanted to join things together and have
it work I don't understand
morning the worst part of working with
spatial data is ahead projections Jill
Julia Sylvie said this well this is a
tweet by her saying me making maps but
not really knowing anything about map
projections I have no idea what I'm
doing
dealing with projections and spatial
data analysis is similar to data munging
you don't like it you're complaining
about it and I am the you know 10th 12th
15th person to complain about data
munging today but I'm doing it for
spatial data so I'm unique so what's
actually going on essentially one of
these data structures has DC sort of in
this you know it's like projected this
way and another one has do you see
projected this way your boundaries
aren't matching up because your latitude
and longitude are mapping to x and y
differently latitude and longitude are
3d coordinates and when you work with XY
you have to push them down into like a
flat surface there are ways of doing
this and if you push them down in
different ways and they don't align up
you can't make a map with both layers so
what we're actually going to do is
straighten out and make sure that these
two layers are the same to do that I'm
going to check the projections so the sq
CRS of the crime layer uses the for
three to six ApS g-code and as we
expected the coordinate reference system
for DC tracts uses the 4 2 6 9 code I
think we have found our problem we can
make them the same this is relatively
straightforward so I'm going to
transform DC crime and DC tracts to the
Maryland state plane projection now
generally it's accepted there are common
projections for you know each state like
there are some projections that are
better for each they like map to an
actual flat map better I do not have
these memorized I have no idea at the
Maryland state plane was 1 0 to 2 8 5 I
just looked up best projection for a DC
and found 10
- 2 8 5 as my code so I decided to use
it now I'm gonna check the productions
again DC crime
okay now the epsg is 10 2 - 8 5 DC
tracks now the EPS G is 10 2 - 8 5 they
look the same I'm good to go
so if I try joining again it works so
you can see that this data structure is
still a simple feature collection now
you can see that I've joined the census
tract on to the offense so now I have
the offense and I have its associated
census tract on the left as you can see
there are a number of things in this
simple feature collection it tells you
that it's a point geometry it tells you
where the bounding boxes which is the
rectangle that surrounds your data and
it also tells you you know the
coordinate projection system or yes so
worked yeah shoot okay now I'm gonna go
ahead and map the crime counts so these
are just the number of crimes you know 0
to 20 20 to 40 for each 60 it looks like
certain parts are a little bit more
crime prone this makes it hard tugger
for sad this snap is not great why we're
map we're mapping a spatially extensive
variable what does what does that mean
that means that the count is related to
the area of the tract so you can imagine
that if the size of your square is
bigger the number of crimes that happen
in is probably going to be bigger -
we're going to fix this as we mentioned
before by dividing by population right
here I'm using the tiny census library
which is a wonderful wonderful package
that I just love and it's so good for
social science researchers and anyone
who's interested in you know census data
at all it pulls from the census API it
gets both census ten-year census data
and American Community Survey data which
is a sample so I'm getting tracked data
I'm looking for population and I'm
getting it for the 4dc which is not a
state but how
to do that for the syntax okay and what
is that return a nice table with the GID
the census tract the variable population
and the census tract again as you can
see there's one one row in here that
doesn't have very much population I'm
inclined to think that this is the mall
but I'm really really curious as to why
there are eight people living in the
mall
okay so now I'm mapping crime rates per
capita and this is a much better map so
this is telling me you know the crime
per a thousand people and I took out the
mall and I think another one that was
just like I think people don't live
there I think one of them was a park
does someone know where that that white
square is anyone know any PC years from
here okay I took out the mall and
something else what is it oh it might be
the potato garden yes local knowledge
very important okay so after I met made
these choropleth maps so the name for
these maps with little squares that are
colored in are called choropleth maps
they are not chloro there's no L it's
just Koro it stands for oh no I used to
know the Greek and now I don't
Koro Greek someone know what that means
and plus it's color yeah color and then
Plath is I think area right it's a color
area coroplast okay so I made a
choropleth map now I'm really curious in
my exploratory spatial data analysis to
see if crime rates and median income are
related so now I'm not mapping the rate
of crime rates rate of crime I'm looking
at a one variable and its relation to
another so I went to grab median income
by tracked this I get from the American
Community Survey data it is in the same
package tidy census but it's a different
variable and now if I look at this data
head of DC income I can now see that I
have the variable and then an estimate
of the income median income which is
quite high and the margin of error don't
worry about the margin of error because
this is a sample they have you know
margins the margins of error on there
okay so now I want to go ahead and map
crimes and median income by the way I'm
doing this not in leaflet but I'm doing
a team app which is my favorite and
preferred mapping package it was
designed by a cartographer and it really
is very extensible and just like base
plotting and ggplot you can do whatever
type of mapping you want you can do it
whatever type of plotting you want as
long as it gives you some sort of way to
work fast with the data when you're
looking at it high you see map because I
know it well you may use leaflet you may
use ggplot even you can do maps and you
do plot but in any case so I've done a
quick dive into spatial data analysis
and made a few maps taking a look at you
know a few things I might find
interesting and look at rates but
there's a lot more that I could do there
might be other local demographic and
socio-economic factors that affect crime
rates so I would do this with spatial
regression and modeling crime in one
area might be linked to crime in another
area so I would look at crime rates and
and see if you have a neighboring track
that has a lot of crime like what is the
effect on you because you know there's
probably some linkage there so that is
called spatial autocorrelation and I
might be interested in spots where crime
is abnormally high or low and that would
be solved with some sort of spatial
clustering trying to identify hot or
cold spots in the city all right so just
a taste of what spatially and analysis
can do for you if you want to know more
feel free to talk to me
[Applause]